this video is brought to you by appsumo
the leading marketplace for digital
entrepreneurs
hi
welcome to another episode of cold
fusion where i cover anything in science
technology business or history
rumors of toyota revealing a prototype
vehicle with a solid state battery first
dropped in late 2020
in january of 2021 i did an episode on
toyota's plans to unveil a prototype car
later in the year today we'll discuss
the event is it hype or has toyota done
something special here in reality it's a
bit of both let's take a look
[Music]
so to quickly recap the reason that a
lot of people are looking forward to
solid state batteries are because of the
advantages that they hold above current
technology
imagine an electric car battery that
provides more than 300 miles or 400
kilometers of range charges in 10
minutes requires no bulky heating or
cooling systems maintains 80 of its
charge capacity over 800 cycles that's
about 240 000 miles or 380 000
kilometers
just by replacing the liquid
electrolytes used in current batteries
with solid material it opens the door
for much better battery technology
these kind of batteries are called solid
state batteries and they're far less
flammable which allows them to run in a
wider temperature window there's also a
lower risk of thermal runaway leading to
a spontaneous combustion energy density
also gets a boost which could lead to
lighter vehicles with longer range all
of this is the promise of solid state
car batteries it's the holy grail that
automakers and manufacturers have been
racing to find
late last year toyota announced that it
would have a running prototype so we
waited and now it's finally arrived in
september toyota showed off a working
version of their prototype on their
youtube channel the video is only 12
seconds long and we don't have much to
go by but reportedly the aim was to test
the battery and collect performance data
and in the pipeline of development this
makes sense design the battery in the
lab and then test it out in the real
world by installing it into a driving
prototype if toyota isn't pulling a
trevor milton and this car is indeed
running and doing what they claim it
actually would be notable because this
would be one of the first times if not
the first time ever that we've seen a
solid state battery running in a car
for context other manufacturers are very
far behind bmw won solid state battery
prototypes by 2025 and mercedes is also
working on one but is far from ready so
seeing a solid state battery in
operation is a treat
toyota which is the world's second
largest automaker do have the track
record to back up the video people do
forget that they released the first
commercially successful fuel battery
hybrid car all the way back in 1997.
okay so the battery is here it seemingly
works but
will it ever be able to make it to mass
production and that's another question
chief technology officer masahiko maida
has stated that the company's solid
state batteries will be in production in
three years
commenting on the unveiling he continues
quote we're focusing on safety long
service life and a high level quality to
produce good low cost and high
performance batteries what toyota values
most is to develop batteries that its
consumers can use with peace of mind
end quote
the aim is to put the battery in hybrids
before using it in a full ev the
thinking goes that hybrids don't fully
rely on the battery just in case there's
an issue
so toyota may be talking a big game but
it seems that they've missed the very
start of the electric wave
toyota already were heading full steam
in the direction of hydrogen technology
no not the trevor milton kind of
hydrogen technology but the real kind
they've doubled down on developing
hydrogen tech over the past decade but
unfortunately for them electric cars
seem to be taking off quicker than they
expected and that seems to be the way
forward for now
toyota didn't want to miss out on this
wave so they've announced that they're
investing 13.6 billion dollars into
battery technology over the next nine
years
this massive sum includes funds for
research development and production
equipment the firm wants to get 200
gigawatt hours of battery capacity by
the end of the decade this battery
supply includes of course the new solid
state batteries
the japanese firm wants to have 10
electric car name plates by 2025 while
reducing battery costs by 30 percent
while also increasing efficiency by the
same amount
so i think toyota may have dragged their
feet in the electric world for just a
bit too long but they're a pretty
innovative automaker for one being of
the traditional era anyway maybe they'll
have no problems catching up to the rest
but as for now toyota is well behind
many other car manufacturers when it
comes to electric car production
they've only just announced their first
mass-produced electric car a couple of
weeks ago which is said to be coming
into production in 2023
meanwhile ford jaguar kia audi porsche
and many others have beaten them to the
punch
so very little is known about the
specific batteries showcased in the
demonstration i wouldn't go as far as to
call the whole thing hype but the demo
still leaves much to be desired granted
though the purpose was just for pulling
metrics for battery performance for
future improvements
for the consumer's sake i do hope that
toyota is truly serious about this
releasing an affordable reliable
solid-state battery would have large
implications not just for the automotive
industry but for the whole transport
industry and the technology world as a
whole as i said in the previous episode
about this i still do think that cost
will remain the biggest barrier for them
so if you want more background on the
solid state story you can watch the
previous episode on the toyota battery
tech i'll leave it in the description
below
and now a quick word from today's
sponsor appsumo appsumo is the leading
marketplace for digital entrepreneurs
they've got all kinds of apps and tools
to make your entrepreneurial life easier
on appsumo you can get my book new
thinking which is usually worth twenty
five dollars for just five dollars it
covers all the key innovations of the
past two centuries who invented what
what inspired them to do what they did
covering those special moments that
changed the world and how it all links
together
a lot of you have really benefited from
reading this amazing story of human
innovation and it shows from the ratings
that the book has received
so thanks for everyone who's read it for
the rest of you this will also make a
great christmas gift if you're thinking
about getting one for your loved ones if
you sign up to appsumo before november
21st you can get great deals on their
black friday sales i use code cold
fusion 20 to get 20 off my ebook
exclusively in the appsumo store so
definitely go check them out links will
be in the description
so thanks for watching my name is tagogo
and you've been watching cold fusion if
you want to listen to the podcast
versions of these episodes i'll leave a
link to them below
okay so i'll see you again soon for the
next episode
cheers guys
have a good one
it's me thinking
[Music]